-The midterm elections
are just months away,
so how concerned should we be
about a foreign power
once again
meddling in our elections?
For a look into how vulnerable
our infrastructure is
to getting hacked,
it's time for "The Check In."
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Bell dings ]
Even before
Trump became president,
he demonstrated
that he didn't really
take the issue of hacking
too seriously.
How do I know?
Well, because he publicly
appealed to a foreign adversary
to continue hacking
into the e-mails
of his opponent at the time,
Hillary Clinton.
-I will tell you this.
Russia, if you're listening,
I hope you're able to find the
30,000 e-mails that are missing.
-That's right -- Trump didn't
just not take it seriously,
he encouraged it.
He's like
one of those parents who say,
"If you kids are gonna drink,
I'd rather you do it
in the house.
And then,
when you're good and buzzed,
I have shrooms in the freezer.
[ Laughter ]
Now, one of the reasons Russia
was able to hack into the DNC
and meddle
in our presidential election
is that we were ill-prepared
for such an attack,
and to be fair,
no one was ready.
There was little preparation
and bumbling responses
from both sides of the aisle.
But now Trump is in charge,
and that's disconcerting,
considering this is how
he talks about cybersecurity
and technology, in general.
-Now, the cyber is so big.
Maybe there's something
with the crazy computers.
You know, in the old days,
everything was better, right?
Now you have to open up things,
press a computer.
Takes you 15 minutes.
You know,
we're in a cyber world.
This is now a cyber world.
Russia is knocking us off.
We talk about the hacking,
and hacking's bad.
And it shouldn't be done.
A hacker,
some guy with a 200 IQ
that can't
get up in the morning.
Okay?
-Sounds like
he's got a handle on it.
[ Laughter ]
It reminds me of old
"Law & Order" episodes,
where someone tries to explain
the Internet to Lennie Briscoe.
"So you're telling me
I can type something here,
and somebody else can read it
in another city?
What a world."
[ Laughter ]
Okay. So it's clear that Trump
is no expert on this topic,
but at least,
when he became President,
he had his choice of anyone
he wanted to put in charge
of cybersecurity,
and he went with a young,
charismatic tech whiz,
Rudy Giuliani,
even though
he couldn't recognize Rudy
when he was sitting
right in front of him.
-I want to introduce
Rudy Giuliani.
And Rudy's very much
of an expert on cybersecurity.
It's been a very important thing
to him and to what he does.
And maybe I'll ask Rudy
to say a few words.
Where is Rudy?
[ Laughter ]
-He was directly
across the table from him!
[ Laughter ]
How was Trump
gonna find the hackers
when he can't even find
Rudy Giuliani at the same table?
No one else
looks like Rudy Giuliani.
Was there another 200-year-old,
bald, beady-eyed man
at the table?
Now, over a year
after that proclamation,
reports say Giuliani's committee
accomplished
pretty much nothing.
But luckily, Trump didn't just
leave Rudy in charge of it all.
He also tasked Jared Kushner
with helping
to lead cybersecurity efforts,
in addition to being in charge
of creating peace
in the Middle East,
fixing the V.A.,
and solving the opioid crisis
while simultaneously
going through puberty.
-Many of our federal systems
are decades old.
We are here to improve
the day-to-day lives
of the average citizen.
That's a core promise,
and we are keeping it.
-That's right --
Jared Kushner, the guy
whose previous relationship
to the Internet was --
I'm guessing --
clearing the search history
before his mom got home?
[ Laughter ]
"Jared, what are you doing?"
"Oh, just the Middle East!
Fixing the Middle East!"
[ Laughter ]
"Just Middle East stuff!"
Back in October,
we thought we'd finally
learn more about what exactly
the administration plans to do
to prevent other countries
from hacking into our databases,
but, unfortunately, Trump's
cybersecurity czar, Rob Joyce,
didn't show up to a hearing on
U.S. cyberdefense strategy.
The White House actually
blocked him from testifying,
citing executive privilege,
resulting in an empty chair with
his name tag during the hearing.
And that only seemed to
encourage Senators
on the committee to
draw attention to his absence.
-The empty chair is outrageous.
We had a foreign government go
at the heart of our democracy.
-We see the person in charge
at an empty seat here today.
-But let's be honest --
even when Trump administration
officials do show up
for questioning,
Senators are also pretty much
just talking to empty chairs.
Just take a look at this.
-I-I-I can't answer...
with definitive
what the conclusion is.
-Yeah, I -- I don't know
what the barriers are.
I don't under--
Senator, I don't understand it.
-Wish I could
give you that number.
I don't know.
-I-I don't know.
-I don't know.
-I have no idea.
-Do I know what now?
-"Know what now?"
[ Laughter ]
Now this particular empty chair,
Attorney General Jeff Sessions,
announced just last month
that the Department of Justice
would create
a new cybersecurity task force
in order
to study election interference.
The DOJ is tasked with providing
a report on its findings
at the end of June.
But beyond that, we don't know
much more about this task force.
But what we already know
about the situation, in general,
is that it may be
a little too late
for more studies and reports.
-Frankly, the United States
is under attack.
-Russian meddling
is a very real threat
in the upcoming election,
and the U.S. is unprepared.
-Until we have
some deterrent capacity,
we are going
to continue to be attacked.
-If we don't
change the dynamic here,
this is gonna continue,
and 2016 won't be viewed
as something isolated.
This is something that
will be sustained over time.
-Now, if that's
not enough to scare you,
that guy right there,
NSA chief Mike Rogers,
who's actually
retiring this Spring,
also indicated that he hasn't
received orders from Trump
to disrupt Russian cyberattacks
targeting elections.
And after months
and months of inaction,
the State Department
was finally given $120 million
to fight
Russian election meddling.
And of that $120 million,
it has spent zero dollars.
Now, to be fair,
the Trump administration
is probably
saving all that money
for goodbye cakes for all the
people leaving the White House.
[ Laughter ]
That's not official.
It's just, we're taping at 6:30,
so it's a guess.
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile, the Senate
is still waiting.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Still waiting to get detailed
cybersecurity plans
from this administration.
Because right now,
Trump's cyber plan
seems to boil down to...
-Do I know what now?
-This has been "The Check In."
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Bell dings ]